it seems already threatening us no no
it's different now Mary Christine and
mamrie and we are going to do just
something for ourselves 2018 I think
could be quantified as a year where
you're over getting shot but you also
want to give self love so I thought
meeting in the middle might be something
along lines of this we're gonna decorate
some dildo
close your eyes y'all cuz two of these
are the same size and one is slightly
different even though many men would say
they're all the same size big money no
whammies no whammies I'm hungry young
for that reference
choose your dilled give me give me
[Music]
you gotta lift the base oh I just do so
I wanna do it too alright we have us a
try now okay okay
how are you gagging when we do it cuz
I'm the only sexy one oh god you guys we
could do this all day I thought new here
knew us that we would take some time
just to be like friends and hang out and
DIY some tilts just like we used to do
in a filmer parties I didn't have
friends in school I'm surprised okay
here's what we're gonna do I'm gonna
give us five minutes to decorate our
dildos
to whatever we want here we go five
minutes on the clock I will say I don't
enjoy being pressured so you're off to a
great start
whoever you want no and she will start
this is not a winning scenario I know
myself I probably shouldn't
now brace where did you acquire these
deals the Internet warriors whoa three
and a half minutes left
oh is that no don't set my alarm
Christine just made a Bernie Sanders
dick in two seconds and I think tickle
is just taking calls
one minute left great one minute here we
go
[Music]
Wow what oh my god
and in the final 25 seconds okay let me
give one squirt to myself garbage truck
outside okay our 2018 dildo decorating
is done so I think Christine you
finished two leaps and bounds ahead of
memory and I so I think I don't like
doing things but you've been squeezing
this so explain to us what this means to
you
Cyclops believe it dream - what is your
dildo well I just think builds they can
be very aggressive the sign of a penis
is scary it's like a loaded gun so I
wanted to bring it down and make it a
little more whimsical okay so that's why
I did a little bird top the dick and
then she goes and laid an egg are the
red dates for period dates you know it I
also have my period every other day
regular old school car to build what I
want to feel like a princess and not
just like I'm being rammed by a dildo I
mean if that Walt Whitman okay I did an
America dealt because it's been you know
just so what we are surrounded by
constantly I could be in the moment
right now I tried to put this nest here
but it just won't stick so it's as if it
wants to get away from where was earth
frog legs represent a lot of different
things
and then I origami fortune teller which
also doesn't get their work it works I
didn't write any numbers on the outside
so you just have to kind of guess
numbers okay so choose a number five
four one two three four say that one
your [__] well there you go
let us know in the comments down below
you thought we did it decorating these
dildos I think we did a great job
me too I think Banksy should do it
yourself I'm gonna call your mom whoa
mrs. bang see ya
make sure you guys go check out video so
we did a memory shuttle and Christine
Shelley she has got a brand new channel
of topping exciting a brand-new old
channel that's reinvigorated this time I
get to start off with a millionfold
Wow no pressure uh of that I don't know
how does your glue stick so well to
yours no no no the heart didn't stick
I'm just saying my eyes
[Music]